bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo tornati su fx incredibili ma di
questa frase ragazzi mi sembrano passati
secoli la l'ultima volta che l'ho detta
infatti non mi ricordo più ultima volta
ricominciare anche se vai facciamo con
uno sguardo tro di partenza che non sono
mai partito lo hanno svolto l'altro
perché gli ultimi nelle spalle uno ti ha
insegnato la non si dà le spalle alla
gente vero sto stronzo di merda ragazzi
non posso vendere come palloncino e
bellissimo come cazzo becco la 3g lega
che non riescono a ca lanciare all'altra
da un attimo ok ho beccato lei di
sbagliato ragazzi non c'è verso non è
possibile
si gioca perché ha trovato uscita così
gli stand e box heavy lo so che sei un
deficiente ma a volte prova ad usare la
testa
eccolo lì perfetto ha inteso
perfettamente quello che volevo dire sì
però magari se ti butti giù petrolio non
riuscirò mai più ecco lo sapevo
ragazzi non riuscirò mai più a vincere
come prima lo so già che non dire che sì
sì qualche a [ __ ] è di così e mi piaci
93 per cento impossible ma come la fanno
ste medie che non l'ho capito perché 93
non poteva essere 94 altro c'è la
vittoria qui sotto vi prendete per
deficiente
evidentemente se i ragazzi è impossibile
sto livello ci abbiate pazienza
si no sì un cazzo sono morto come ma
come si fa a far schifo dai dai dai dai
dai che questa passò alla storia per
padre uk devo andare no kat
ok non crea eccolo lì perfetto ho
rovinato i sogni di gloria perché avevo
fatto una cosa epica ho perso una gamba
ma ne è valsa la pena ce la posso fare
grandissimo che io ho perso la testa ma
ne è valsa la pena
ho perso la bce cielo nel culo ragazzi
ormai oppure di giocare ad happy meals i
livelli sta diventando sempre più strani
non capito bene bravo luke bravo nuke
vinci così vinci per tuo padre ha mai
messo la mia testa a figlio l'importante
è che abbiamo vinto per chi se ne frega
lettere tanto è l'ultima cosa di band
mary had my age come cazzo si dice
pronto matrimonio in poche parole cosa
devo fare
devo buttare il mio post di dall'acqua
che cazzo
ok qualcuno mi spiega il senso di sta
roba ragazzi non ho capito il senso a
drogba
ok sono aggrappati faccio parte dello
stand dino vai in su maledizione si sono
fatte raffa vieni gioco a me è stronzo
ragazzi chiesto freezer che riuscì se
non li faccio i capelli a 5 euro non
perfetto come non detto mi sembra chiaro
che hai detto di no per burlando pro mi
chiedo se non secoli io non faccio un
arpu un run l'altro ecco sono partiti di
merda ma non importa
spero di vinto ecco lolita spesso lo so
non mi sono fatto niente
giuro ti può fare una partita senza
morire in 4 secondi marito è bravo bravo
o due peni perché perché mimì penzola
l'intestino non si correva ho capito che
non si può fare inutile qui sto provando
da mezz'ora ma non c'è sosta pedalando
grande così è la vita eccola lì la
vittoria alla fine già facciamo ci
mettiamo dei secoli ma ce la facciamo in
un modo o nell'altro almeno quello su
181 credo sia tipo soft gr il padre lo
zio ragazzi ma che cazzo di schifo è ok
vabbè io faccio finta di non aver visto
animo avanti perché non importa ci ho
lasciato anche una gamba guardata la
rossa come souvenir ragazzina e macabra
sta cosa hai detto che non me la dai
ecco questo è un massaggio che ti offro
io gratis caso mi si è impigliata alla
gamba che non ho com'è possibile cosa
cazzo è questo è normale
cioè io io è ok io io io non ho fatto un
cazzo se chiedete io non ho fatto un
cazzo è stata una piacevolissima hargita
ultimate trolling che cazzo perché si
amano altimetro adesso ho capito io non
devo andare di qua devo andare indietro
perché questi son strong lo sapevo sei
stufo ragazzi è stata mi hanno [ __ ]
di brutto però è qualcosa mi dice che
non devo andare di sotto meglio ci va
ecco lo sapevo ragazze che cazzo succede
mi sembra di essere in bo vinto ok
perché non ho vinto mi stanno prendendo
per il culo cosa ragazzi che cosa cambia
torna indietro ma [ __ ] lo sapevo
che va beh allora sinistra ma non lo
devo tantissimo dov'è la mia testa non è
delhi come abbia fatto ma va bene così è
una cosa a [ __ ] ragazzi sta diventando
alquanto difficile
ok perfetto mi sono fermato prima perché
mi sono ricordato che qualche mid e
capitano non so perché come cazzo
e allora siete stronzi mi uccido si ok
ma cazzo sono non sono ma [ __ ] una
cosa posso ancora andare avanti
posso ancora andare avanti così ma
allora mai che ci siamo bikers cos'è sta
speight forma facciamo uno spy fold e
100 anno vediamo che siamo pro by yoox
la busta non serve un cazzo perché sono
sfera in mezzo ai [ __ ] che vado vado
con luke no io che l'ha presa in pieno
in faccia si ok non che non chiedetemi
come non c'è bisogno
red rocks ragazzi da secoli ma facciamo
rock swing da come si deve mai slam
amico mio non c'è bisogno di aiuti
grazie non ho bisogno delle tue fottute
indicazioni ma va che cacchio caso però
si fa allora terminata sì l'ho preso
oddio ragazzino non mi chiedete cosa c'è
il tutorial try to go like this
ma va qualcuno io vado come mi pare ok
non sei tu a diluire cose strane so se
voglio che vada avanti anche con naso
tipo come sto facendo adesso tra [ __ ]
dai premi su off ed io penso che se ci
provo un altro miliardo di volte non ci
riesco
cazzo tipo 25 anni dopo eccolo lì
perfetta allora io non mi stacco di
quindi anche se fosse l'ultima cosa che
faccio ok adesso vai avanti lo stesso ve
ne frega un cazzo
no [ __ ] sto livello mi sono
articoli non mi piace lo faceva schifo
già dall'inizio ma stage al ragazzo ma
capra per prima cosa ragazzi ogni
lanciare una bella sciolta in faccia
perfetto l'ho mancato di brutto
la possiamo fare baia di farmi vedere un
lancio davvero pressler e deeside
braccini mi dispiace ma non va a fan
culo
ok il nuovo cappello di nonno ciak
spacca di brutto suv lo swing che cazzo
mi rappresenta stolida eco
sono con noi è un'altalena io posso
volare non può volare sarò si può volare
che cosa fa ragazzi aiuto mi sono
staccata e [ __ ] no aspettate che
mi arriva infatti quasi che cazzo
succede ragazzi è bellissima statale non
vorrei vorrei andarci io se possibile si
può lasciare spazio al bravo così
ragazzi ok si è diventata peggio di quel
che pensassi però ho ritrovato il mio
braccio in effetti vedeva ragazzi se
riesco a trovare qualcosa dalla fabi
favi eccolo lì abbiamo sentito qualcosa
di nuovo ragazzi che ormai fa vigeva il
su sarpom premi z sopravvivi che la
nutella sia con te non è questa ragazza
è la carica giusta per iniziare un
livello come si deve ok
ho vinto a caso praticamente perché
chiesto tizio province prova questo per
farvi prova questo e poi divise lando se
nulla è impossibile per te alla ragazzi
voi lo sapete che so che se ti dirò di
non andare giù
tu ci andrai comunque quindi non andare
giù e se non sai perché me lo chiedi ok
forse ho capito perché poi ci hai
preparato la trappola qui sotto lo so ma
io vinco lo stesso perché riuscirò ad
arrivare a trovare petrolio olè olè di
gas cisco che scusate la reazione un po
esagerata questo è da replay questo ed
ha [ __ ] un assassino sapevo che avrei
vinto lo stesso in qualche modo fa vj's
boltro ragazzi facciamo un volto che
ancora non ho fatti oggi ciao favi
eccoti un difficile boltro per te grazie
mille amico mio vediamo se riesco a fare
qualcosa di decente a ragazzi ce la
posso fare primo tentativo primo [ __ ]
tentati sì ma se c'hai braccini di una
mosca barca tra tutte lì le ho mandate
ragazzi non è così e [ __ ] altre
tre palle dammi la mano maledizione
domina cazzo di ma non fate passare uk
marito
i ragazzi sono sono vivo non so come
sono vivo non so fottutamente come 20
[ __ ] mi sono rotto le palle
mi son rotto le palle boltro mi sono
rotto allora dovrei uscire lo posso fare
luke di merda devi toglierti come ha
fatto a non cadere allora adesso io
questa pagina gliela lancio nel culo
giusto per niente non non cade
[ __ ] devi cade bravo bambino
stupido all'ordine seles cucinati cose
perfetto ma non me ne frega un cazzo di
vincere voglio solo seppellirlo vivo
tipo che è successo qui mi sono arrivate
3000 padri e adesso chi è che sono pi
anelka pranzi direi che posso concludere
qui era già perché sono sono ormai
distrutto ed i ragazzi io e luke
speriamo che il video vi sia piaciuto
soprattutto sul culo sottosopra e quindi
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto il cover solito
lasciato un commento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e con i video trovate
nella descrizione aspetto siamo riusciti
scrive the rich vediamolo passioni le
belle ragazze